Speaker 1: OK, as many of you know, I am
not a Christian. I truly don't understand
that much about Christianity, but I do feel
like I have a sense of crazy when I see it.
And today, I have video for you of Pastor Dan
Bourgoyne from California playing with dog poop,
shoving his hands into dog poop during a sermon
to, I guess, make some kind of point about sin
or something like that. Now, I want to
warn people, if you're having breakfast,
if you're having lunch, whatever you're doing,
there is going to be video here of the pastor
doing scatological play with dog poop on stage
during a sermon. Now, the con there is it
shockingly, there is there is context here, which
is my discussion yesterday of the tax exemption
that churches receive in the United States. I
didn't I mentioned it offhandedly, but I got a ton
of emails from people talking about David. I agree
or I disagree with your point about churches and
tax exemptions. So warning we are going to look at
a video here in which this guy is playing with dog
poop. Check out the build up to this stunt. And
importantly, consider whether this type of thing
is what we, the taxpayers should be subsidizing
so that churches can do this and yet not pay taxes
and not pay taxes. Let's take a look.
Speaker 4: So do you know what God
equates a sin in the Bible he equates to? Filth,
whoa! In the Bible, no, this is not a brownie.
No, this is not a Snickers bar.
I own tubal M.S. in my life.
This is Great Dane.
Speaker 2: Dear God, do you know what
Speaker 1: a crappy idea, guys
Speaker 4: God sees? Now, listen,
this is important. Psalm 141 verse to me.
My prayer be set before you like what? Like
incense made the lifting of my hands
be like the evening sacrifices.
Your sin, God says, has hidden my face from you
so that I will not hear. So when you come in
and you're saying God, the gods of my life compete
with who you are, but I'm declaring that I belong.
Speaker 1: Are you guys understanding
how this is building up to smearing
himself with dog poop? Because I'm not
Speaker 4: you. God says this is what I see.
Speaker 2: Whoa.
Speaker 1: Really trying to
score some brownie points with God, we might say.
Speaker 4: And what I say comes up like incense
before me. Oh, my God. And what's going
on in your soul? I can see in ways nobody.
Speaker 1: He's playing with
it like Clay now I can see.
Speaker 4: And so you know what you say, oh, God
created me a clean heart and renewing me a right
spirit cast me not from the presence and take
not the Holy Spirit from me. And you got chunks
coming off of your thumb and God is saying, what
are you what do you want me or do you want you? Do
you want your ways or do you want my ways? Because
you can't have what you're getting the way.
Speaker 1: What a crappy way to make a point,
don't you think? So that's that's a church there.
Tax-Exempt A Bourgoyne quotes Psalm one forty
one. I guess it's verse two or line two about
lifting one's hands up to God. I think maybe the
point he's trying to make is that we are merely
dog poop without God or something like that. So
what is this desperation? Is this mental illness?
Is that what is it? Is it grifting of some kind?
And at some point, if you're spending your Sunday
digging through your own dog's poop on church, in
a church, on a stage, don't you have to reconsider
whether God has laid out a good life for you at
some point? Isn't that a question? Is this what
God wants you to be doing, playing with poop on a
in a church? And this is what gets me back again
to the blanket tax exemption for churches.
I get it. If a church runs a soup kitchen,
organize it separately, give them a tax exemption.
If a church even runs a school, even if it's a
religious education, if they're doing good
education otherwise and teaching real stuff,
let them organize as a nonprofit educational
institution. But we have millions of people
who are lacking health care. We have hunger in the
United States. We have people without homes, etc.
But this guy gets a tax exemption for scatological
games. Something is very, very wrong. And I
remain convinced that the blanket tax exemption
for churches needs to be done away with. I'm not
saying there are situations. I'm not saying
there aren't situations where it makes sense
that a church would be tax exempt. But this
stuff has to stop. This stuff absolutely has
to stop. Send me your thoughts. And, you know,
just just a crappy story to go to break on here.